in and so are you a changed banker now
glob we've been heightened I think I
become more cautious and critical when I
consider the risks of reason I never
used to deal with that aspect for the
kind of intensity we do today so in that
respect I'm sure the crisis has changed
me definite hurt if anyone knows the
risks of a financial crisis its Martine
blessing chairman of the board and Kamat
spunk he gave an interview for made in
Germany it's not you're still chairman
of the board today how did you manage
that avid i justed up to the pressure he
also got some help from friends on the
supervisory board and in government his
grandfather was once president of the
Bundesbank but none of them could save
blessing from the fall he took after his
acquisition of today's nabong it
triggered the biggest crisis in co mot
spunks history with his bank facing
collapse he had to turn to the German
government for a bailout worth billions
of euros c'mon spunk was now dependent
on the state blessing those the downside
of too much dependence by banks on
governments and vice versa the sovereign
bonds the bank's pile up can eventually
spell their undoing montine blessing
warns so banks really ought to put
limits on how many bonds they buy
and the mt mavi a lot has changed about
how we handle our sovereign bonds but
not much has changed about how secure
they are and since greece we know that
not even bonds in the eurozone are
secure people aren't used to humility
from a big banker but at least he knows
how to put that new humility across and
advertising
why don't people trust banks anymore
because strategy is meant as a kind of
apology to the taxpayers and the
customers does Germany need a bank that
carries on as before kamat spunk
employees think out loud about the
bank's battered image what does your
bank really do for companies the truth
is we have always been there for that
Emil as I did millions of euros went
into the campaign if it makes the
viewers think it's achieved its aim
because I can guns unless if a call from
Lewis dequindre called until znalazlem
gets the freakness become fuzzy arts
fight in 2008 we cut a lot of bonuses
even to where we had lawsuits filed
shrieking we won some of the suits and
we lost some some of my colleagues and I
even testified in court Alec lagging
hunger for one we wanted to show very
clearly that the kind of thing that went
on here in the past is not going to
continue von Hagens Clady monstery and
ass wasn't a [ __ ] hyper serious gates
only fighter but then you increase the
bonuses again prz done let's give his
allies with a gap or once a certain
performance returned we bump them up a
little but if you compare the total
amounts going for bonuses today with
what kamata bank and Desna were paying
at the peak in 2007 you'll see that
today we're not even at twenty-five
percent to the variable remuneration
being paid back then stumbles and valley
habla forgotten go now martin blessings
every step is under close scrutiny
he's not yet finished overhauling
Germany's second largest bank he's
promising less investment in sovereign
bonds real estate and shipping and more
investment in medium-sized business and
return to private customers he tied Zola
I think we're through the worst of it
but it'll take a while before things
start picking out I daolon if you could
do it over would you still buy the
today's nabong yeah yes but more like
six weeks after the Lehman bust not two
weeks before that would have saved the
taxpayers billions